qué mecanismos puede llevar a cabo la
unión europea para poner un tope a los
precios del gas y cómo puede el bloque
sobre todo paliar las posibles
consecuencias de esa decisión
bueno la verdad que eso depende siempre
de los acuerdos políticos
encontrados dentro del marco de la
propia institución de la unión europea
de bruselas especialmente
ahí va a tener sus propias dificultades
porque recordemos que la unión europea
tiene sus divisiones respecto de
naciones quizás más cercanas a rusia
como puede ser hungría y ahí lo que
vamos a tener que ver es también el peso
que va a tener en definitiva lo que
empieza a decir por ejemplo turquía que
está diciendo que las sanciones están
jugando en contra de la propia europa y
en definitiva
lo que podemos ver es que si tenemos un
alza de los precios en los próximos días
de mi todo por la inflación que conduce
el recorte de la energía puede haber un
periodo en el que esas divisiones se
acrecienten y finalmente tengamos un
desgaste de la posición mayoritaria
europa que es la de aplicar el tope yo
realmente veo muy difícil que llegue en
esa situación porque la amenaza es
es cierto hoy tenemos un bloqueo de ese
acceso al gas ruso y las consecuencias
son muy graves para europa porque no
está preparada en el corto plazo para
asumir semejante costo
para putin dice que las sanciones no han
afectado la economía rusa pero siendo
europa uno de sus principales clientes
puedes realmente darse el lujo de cortar
los suministros de gas y petróleo
creo que en un corto plazo sí sí en
tanto en cuanto entienda el kremlin que
el mensaje es más importante que la
entrada de enero que está dispuesta a
perder recordemos que el gas ruso y el
petróleo están siendo derivados a nuevos
puertos llamémosle especialmente a la
india china que ha tomado una decisión
por ejemplo china de crear un acceso al
gas ruso y eso permite pensar un flujo
de dinero
sumamente grande para la federación
pensando también que la negociación
entre estos nuevos socios o mejor dicho
esta nueva elección de socios
mayoritarios viene dado por un descuento
del gas entonces lo que tenemos es una
situación en la que rusia vende gas o
petróleo con descuentos a actores fuera
de la esfera europea para que después de
esos países se vendan europa el gas y el
petróleo mucho más caro es decir hay de
tres actores hay dos que ganan seguro en
las y europa siempre pierden por lo
tanto hoy tiene un margen para
permitirse hacer ese cálculo de poder
ahora en otros temas políticos del
kremlin sugieren que el próximo 4 de
noviembre rusia podría celebrar
referendos en las regiones ocupadas en
ucrania después de la experiencia de
crimea como serían recibidos dichos
referendos por la comunidad
internacional
creo que negativamente
especialmente pues se dan en el marco de
un conflicto armado no no sea en digamos
el mismo contexto que se dio el
referéndum en crimea que fue una
situación más bastante gris llamémosle
porque se estaba dando dentro de un
proceso de
cambio muy grande político en ucrania
donde en europa y los eeuu tenían una
posición muy clara respecto de que iban
a hacer
con la decisión del mayor recordemos
eso fue en un periodo de tiempo
relativamente corto en el que se
produjeron situaciones muy contundentes
en en ucrania y que permitieron la
llegada de los famosos hombres verdes
en crimea desde la base de sebastopol y
dieron cierta legitimidad al referéndum
a partir de la
mayoritaria presencia de una idea rusa
incremento no es el caso de estos nuevos
escenarios